that radical Muslims want to bring
Sharia to the United States Syria is
already here he's here how is that me
smiling at all of you and you we are
following the Sharia very soon we are
going to pray the third prayer of the
day which is part of the Sharia in U.S
we are practicing Sharia if I go to
Chicago downtown and give five dollars
or food to a poor person I am following
Sharia if I go home and take care of my
parents I am following Sharia if I'm
going up in the morning and uh you know
working to get food on the table
I am following Sharia if I'm being nice
to women not objectifying them I'm
following Sharia if I am having rallies
Against Racism in this country I am
foreign